in reviewing this movie this what I'm
gonna bring up it's not gonna really
matter it's not gonna matter a really
rampage the game has one visual plot
queue and that is when you die you
shrink down into a human being so by
implication these monsters are actually
human beings that's not in this movie I
feel like that would have been much more
interesting to have these monsters who
are actually human beings and you're
really conflicted they're victims we
can't just kill them you do feel like
that with George but like why didn't why
didn't they just follow that whatever
it's a video game let's review
[Music]
rampage so rampage is the latest attempt
to prove to the masses that video game
movies can be good rampage stars the
rock he has a friend named George who is
an ape George comes into contact with
this chemical that makes him grow
exponentially and makes him rage out and
so does a crocodile and a wolf now these
monsters are gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
Chicago and only the rock can stop them
talk about what I liked in the movie I
have to fast-forward to the last 15-20
minutes of the movie because the last
part of the movie is actually what's fun
the last part of the movies what people
came for which is the rampage was the
monsters beating the hell out of the
city beating the hell out of each other
that's the fun that's when the movie
really sits back in his recliner commits
to its absurdity you can actually go oh
yeah that's good time I'm not gonna lie
the monster on Monster action that was
happening at the end I had a grin on my
face it was dumb but it was dumb fun I
also like Jeffrey Dean Morgan Jeffrey
Dean Morgan is fantastic in this movie
though Jeffrey Dean Morgan in this movie
is a variant of negan if you're like
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is gonna do what
Johnny Depp did after Jack Sparrow or
really you kind of see Jack Sparrow and
a lot of stuff he did or at least at the
very least Johnny Depp was just always
kind of a weirdo in his roles made him a
lot of money I feel like Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is going to be a variant of negan
going forward I'm not sick of it yet
eventually I probably will be but I just
love them it's negan the government
agent he just cracked me up in a world
where this movie has two easy lines it's
a solid block of cheese you got to eat
for a very long time but Jeffrey Dean
Morgan delivering it he makes it work
alright let's talk about the rest of the
movie which I called the dumb this
movies a cheesy sharknado movie which
would be fine if it were on TV where
it's you know free I guess you gotta pay
for cable what might stream online for
free which gives you gotta pay for
Internet but nothing's free you have to
live to experience anything you got to
pay to live what do you have to be
ticket price a lot less worth it and a
sharknado movie starring the rock how
did that happen I don't know what it
happened there were some knobs to the
rampage arcade game which I found fun
there's actually a coin-op rampage
arcade game in the background in one
scene which is some fourth wall break
and [ __ ] and part of the cheesiness I'm
talking about comes from these two
corporate people who really didn't come
across as a couple of villains like
super villains yeah we're business super
villains like Lex Luthor but not really
the cheesiness doesn't stop there at all
it's in the concepts and delivery of
everyone's thoughts in action I'm
talking about the kind of stuff where
people are spitballing like okay well
there's a problem what do we do you know
like what about that oh good guess it's
exactly what we need all right how do we
use this I know what about that oh
that's exactly what we're need any we
can hack the server from the thermostat
oh wow would work
and I don't know maybe that's possible
my thermostat is analog as [ __ ] it's
like every idea for a solution anyone
had to fix a problem in this movie was a
long shot and every long shot worked the
first time every time
this wasn't when the crocodile is coming
on to the scene in Chicago and it's
swimming up the Chicago River of Chicago
canal I think it was a Chicago canal in
this military war room people like sir
there's movement in the canal this
military officers like we don't have any
subs in that area there nobody subs in
Chicago no [ __ ] [ __ ] no one was
questioning that why did anyone ever
jump to subs why did you even have to
explain that the movies stupid is dumb
it's ridiculous but the end brings it
home in a way where it might actually be
a good time if you're drunk yeah or this
one might be a spoiler it's one line at
the end of the movie if you care I don't
know muted this is one's there Jeffrey
Dean Morgan comes up to the rock at the
end and he's like thanks for saving the
world I was like the world or Chicago
you know the place of submarines well
it's a fun Ludacris movie for you
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]